if tiger sharks are showing up in the
shallows
in greater numbers then it's not because
of deep blue
the reason for the attacks remains
elusive
but while scouring the ocean for an
explanation
experts come across something else that
also ensnares
large amounts of a tiger shark's prey
but it's not another sea creature in
fact
it walks on two legs i think
the reason why we are having more sharks
here actually is because the amount of
fishing that's been going on
this is one of the island's most popular
activities
sport fishing every year
recreational anglers haul in more than
two million pounds of fish
that means that on any given day off the
big island
there are hundreds of fish being caught
and reeled in
[Music]
and for scientists like dr dan huber
these hooked sea creatures may be
attracting sharks
a struggling fish as its body is
twitching a bit that motion is giving
off
low frequency sounds and shark hearing
happens to be tuned into low frequency
sounds
this is definitely something that could
attract a number of sharks to the same
area
so could sport fishing be drawing tiger
sharks into the shallows
thereby increasing the risk of an
accidental run-in with people
according to fisherman rick rieger it
comes down to where the best
sport fishing takes place
to demonstrate he heads out to an area
well known for the popular pastime
okay so this is our bottom here we have
some of the steepest drop-offs in the
whole world right here
this is where you're going to see your
tuna your mahi-mahi your ono
your marlin this location
could hold a vital clue to solving the
mystery
called the pelagic zone this open water
abyss
extends thousands of miles between the
continental shelves
it's home to an array of large sea
creatures
whales manta rays
big game fish and some of the most
dangerous sharks
on earth
[Music]
[Music]
you